well why don't I start so let me thank
you for coming i know everyone at this
point of the conference has mathematica
fatigue and so let me try and get you
excited about this project which I sort
of think like why would anyone else but
me be interested in this and I think the
selling points are first of all i'm
going to show you what our link can do
which is actually a lot and it's very
easy to use and very powerful I think
what I've got is a little bit of a
rosetta stone project here in which you
can see how to do various things in our
and then also how to do it in
Mathematica and how to use some of the
our package ideas as kind of a hint for
some ways that we might make progress
with Mathematica data set objects to
also show you how you can handle these
are fairly large data sets that I'm
going to be talking about today and to
see how things scale and then of course
you might also be interested in the
Affordable Care Act itself and it's a
fairly important thing and I think
originally I this talk was going to be a
little bit different because we were
going to have data that was going to be
released by the government in early
October and it was I was going to be
able to contrast the rates that are
available on the various health care
exchanges with those that had previously
been available but i am now told that
the i know the data has not been
released and as a sort of a I don't know
a kick in the pants i think it's going
to be released tomorrow so doesn't do me
much good so this talk is morphed a
little bit originally I was going to
talk about some testimony that I gave
before Congress this summer on some of
the financial stability issues in the
Affordable Care Act I'll still talk
about that a little bit but i'll also
just talk about some very large data
sets that are now out there just waiting
to be mined the data that we've never
had before about the functioning of
american health insurance markets so
with that just to fill you in one of the
things that I was asked to talk about
with Congress this summer was um this
issue of rate hikes as some of you may
know there's a projection that the rate
hikes for health insurance plans are
going to be quite substantial this year
in Illinois its projected for example
they'll be about a twenty to twenty one
percent increase in gross health
insurance premiums for people who are
buying their policies on the exchange
and so the question is why and so one of
the theories that was being bad about
was that this was due to the diminution
of a subsidy program that the
government's been running for insurers
on the health care exchanges called
transitional reinsurance and so one of
the things I wanted to do was to see was
that really a substantial factor in the
price increases that were projected to
see the short answer is no but in order
to do that what I really needed to do
was to get data on the expected claims
under the Affordable Care Act and the
since insurers don't tend to publish
their claims data they kind of regard
that as proprietary the source for this
was a bunch of calculators that the
government maintains in Excel
spreadsheets and so what I needed to do
was to suck in those excel spreadsheets
which are of course not in a format
remotely nice for what I wanted to do
with them transform them and then to use
them in order to do the needed
computations for how much was this
reinsurance that's being provided to
health insurers really worth okay so in
the course of that exercise and
subsequently I ended up writing it not a
huge amount of code but some code that
might have some value for more than me
and this is code that basically does
things like take CSV data and turn it
into a mathematica data set it takes an
hour data frame object the R has data
frames that it uses how many of you have
used our okay so must we know this um
and it converts it into a mathematic a
data set object and vice versa we can go
from Mathematica data set object and
construct in our data frame which can
then be shipped back to our and so one
of the things I wanted to do for this
project was to make dual use or hybrid
use of our in Mathematica
easier some of the other things I wanted
to do is are many of you familiar with
ours deep liar package okay it's a
package for manipulating data I think
it's a fairly nice package it's a
friendly package and so one of the
things I wanted to do was kind of
emulate that with in Mathematica and I
don't claim that this has but yes yes I
could I don't claim that this has been
particularly elegant or successful and
I've had some nice conversations with
tally here at the conference on how it
might be done better but if you're
desperate and can't wait till
Mathematica 10.4 11 or whenever this
happens this may give you some
suggestions about how to do this sort of
thing you also may have seen a talk by
Alan cavity which was a sort of a
parallel approach kind of like that you
know the two people who discovered
Neptune together except nothing so
profound and you can you can use either
his coat or my code but there's a
variety of things that are in here that
I think might be of use to you in any
event what this ended up trying to show
and there's a lot of cleaning up code
here which I don't think would interest
anyone but the most die-hard individual
was sort of a combination of use of our
and mathematica in order to conclude
when we got to the bottom line and
joining various data sets together
there's a good old left join in our
there's a left join done in Mathematica
and by the time we were and then we had
emerged in some other data by the time
we were all done with it I was able to
basically show that really although the
reinsurance is quite valuable to the
insurers there was not going to be that
much of a diminution of it between 9th
between 2015 and 2016 for many of the
plans such that they would really be
responsible for the premium rate
increases we're seeing that is this was
sort of forensic work you might think of
it is trying to isolate causes for the
increase in premiums and I think there's
a fairly strong negative proof here that
it's unlikely that in many cases that
the diminution and the government
reading
insurance program is involved and that
there may be other factors that are
responsible for the premium hikes so
that was kind of the the summer proj the
other thing by the way just so you know
it's one of the things I wanted to see
is is this actuarial value calculator
which is being used right now to
regulate insurers and the sales of
insurance on health care exchanges is it
even internally consistent that is they
have various columns that are supposed
to have mathematical relationships to
each other and so I probed this and it
turns out that is not it is not
consistent which gives me two levels of
trouble one is it makes me a little
cautious about my initial conclusions
because they were premise thanh the
government's actuarial value calculator
being correct and secondly it's a sort
of worries me that we've got a
fundamental instrument of policy here
which when you look at what it purports
to do and do the computations
independently does not it does not match
and I've sent letters off to Congress
about this and of course gotten no
response so in any event the project
that I've tried to undertake since then
is to look at some of these other
databases that have been published
recently and these are things like very
large databases on attributes of plans
sold on the various exchanges of which
as you can see since 2014 there have
been forty nine thousand nine hundred
and seventy-two plans there are a
hundred and twenty-six V attributes on
each plan and to see what we can find
out about that data there's also a
assume this is all coming out of some
gargantuan Oracle or SQL database with
lots of related tables and so they don't
publish the whole data frame they
published the the pieces and so one of
the things I want to try to do is to put
some of these pieces together and see
what relationships we can develop but
also simply to do there is you know I
don't think in this whole talk I'm doing
anything fancier than multiplication
okay it's just very basic pointing your
telescope a data that's never been seen
before and try
to look at sort of what sort of
insurance system in fact do we have okay
so there's a fair amount of the usual
horrible cleaning that one has to do
with data which got me into the
mathematica type system and just you
know things that people do that are dumb
like coding percentages as strings
rather than as numbers okay so then
you've got identified which columns have
percentages in them and turn them into
numbers or they can't spell yes and no
consistently which one might have
thought was not a great challenge but in
any event on producing additional files
that other people can use so I want to
hear some things that we can see right
off we can see that there's been an
increase between 2014 and 2015 on the
number of issuers that are selling plans
on the health care exchanges we can see
an increase even if we take out dental
plans of which are a surprising number
there's still an increase we will see if
that persists in 2016 my suspicion is
that we're going to see kind of a
leveling off of the number of insurers
we can break that down by by state see
what's going on on a state level we can
break that down by service area which
for an individual is kind of what's
important so that for example if you
live in I think this is Arkansas service
area to what's important to you is that
there may only be two plans that are
available to you or to issuers that are
available to you and so you need to be
start to be concerned about the level of
competition in those states and for
example there are a lot of health care
some of you may have read in the news
there are a bunch of health insurer
mergers that are being proposed and
trying to go through and so if there are
only two carriers and though it's those
are the two carriers that are being
merged that might be of some concern to
you and here's a histogram showing ok
how many issuers are there in each
service area both in 2014 and 2015 we
can do the same sort of data analysis
looking at metal levels some of you may
know that these plans come in various
gradations depending on how much they
pay on average with platinum being the
best and bronze
being the least valuable is and
catastrophic and so we can see where has
the growth in policies been some of you
may know there are different styles of
plans in the united states that are HMOs
and PPOs and EPOS and POS s and we can
also start to take a look at where the
growth has been and in fact just have a
side point I think what we're going to
see in 2016 and I think it's actually
probably most important development
we're going to see is I think we're
going to see a leveling off or
diminution in the level of number of
ppos that are being sold in sure seem to
be losing money on PPOs and therefore
you're seeing and for example in
Illinois Blue Cross will no longer sell
you the same kind of PPO it's sold last
year there's that there's another cruddy
PPO that it's willing to sell you but
not the nice one so these are all things
that we're able to do and I think if you
look through the code which I won't you
know it's impossible to read code like
this and a talk but if you look through
the talk you'll see that I'm doing the
same sorts of things in Mathematica and
are and you'll see how one can do it in
either system we can also look at the
there are different types of contracts
that are available we can see how those
have been handled some of you may know
that one of the new things in health
insurance is tearing in which if you go
to the the cheap doctor you might get
reimbursed for eighty percent of your
claim but if you want to go to the fancy
doctor you might only get reimbursed
sixty percent of your claim and so one
of the things I wanted to look at is has
there been a growth in tiering it turns
out there's not been or this issue of do
you need a referral to go see a
specialist what's been the historical
trend in that how does that vary
according to whether you have an EPO a
PPO and HMO does it vary depending on
whether you what metal level plan that
you have and again I will not pretend
that any of this analysis is
particularly sophisticated it's simply
database grouping operations followed by
aggregation operations on the group
data although I will say that it is not
often self-evident how to do that in
Mathematica and so this code i think has
some utility and giving you some ents as
to how as of 2015 it might be done maybe
in 2016 will have some better mechanisms
um any of you set any of you in wellness
programs so okay one person these
wellness programs are basically designed
to induce you to either listen to things
that will make you healthier or actually
to engage in activities that will make
you healthier and if you do them you may
get a it's usually articulated as a you
know a subsidy on your insurance premium
the other way of looking at it of course
is that if you don't do it then it's a
tax on your insurance premium and so one
of the issues is some people are fearful
that these wellness programs are a
surrogate for bad bad old fashioned
underwriting so for example supposing
the Wellness Program is you've got to be
able to walk a mile in less than 20
minutes um well you know people who have
health problems are going to have
greater difficulty meeting that goal and
so some people are concerned that
wellness programs can mask medical
underwriting and there are all sorts of
regulations that are designed to prevent
that but and then even one issue simply
as to what extent are wellness programs
prevalent in the United States and at
least in the exchange plans and for the
first time I think we're getting a good
handle on that anyone here subject to
disease management so another idea is
that for people who have chronic and
expensive diseases we can start to be
ensure can throw responsibility for
management of those diseases onto the
individual and if they are good people
and comply with the program and take
their puffers and take their blood
pressure frequently and and I don't know
what what you do with pregnancy but in
any event you again get some sort of
reward on your policy may be lower cost
sharing levels and so one of the things
I wanted to look at was the extent to
which health plans were sub were
subjecting
to the disease management what diseases
we're going to be subject to disease
management was there a trend in it and
so we can do fun things like make pie
charts out of Mathematica data frames
what is this looking at oh this is
looking at prevalence according to a
type of plan and the like and then
finally while we're you know playing
with Mathematica graphics one of the
things we might want to do is to see
whether there's any geographic
dispersion in the use of things such as
disease management and so we can you
know do certain operations and here you
can see me let me just stop for a second
have you take a look at this code not
that it's great code but it gives you a
flavor I think of one way that you might
want to write your data set processing
operation you'll notice a lot of use of
postfix operators I think that's act and
that is sort of the are deep liar way of
proceeding is that you use these postfix
operators I think the way that's the
reason that's attractive is that in fact
corresponds to the way that people think
about databases that is it is sort of a
procedural kind of thing take your data
filter out the ones that don't have some
characteristic then group everybody
together according to some
characteristic then for each of those
groups proceed to find out some
aggregate statistic on some some of the
the data contained in there and so you
can see this this flavor of programming
style being used here and I think it's
something that is a helpful way to go
about things in any event we end up with
you know the usual geo region value plot
which does so some difference in the use
of disease management throughout the
United States and I honestly I'm not
sure I detect the pattern it doesn't
seem to be particularly prevalent in the
southeast and quadrants of the Midwest
seems like Utah and Texas and Oklahoma
in West Virginia
their disease management and again it's
it's really there to illustrate the for
one thing it illustrates that health
insurance is not a unitary phenomenon in
the United States there's a great deal
of variation amongst the states and
regions and also simply as a way of
showing you that you can integrate
various parts of mathematica together in
ways that are kind of convenient to make
attractive plots yes that means there's
no data for example California is not
part of the federal exchange system they
have their own exchange and so the data
I have is only for those states that
basically report to healthcare.gov what
they are up to so I don't see New York
in there and there were other gaps yes
in fact there should be in the materials
for this session I was told they was
there big and so I think they were
chunking through uploading them but
unpassable there should be all this data
okay and it's I've got it in CSV form
some of it I have in da tardy a form
which is the equivalent of dot M X Files
and so you can upload it in a variety of
formats if you want the raw data you
just before I've cleaned it up and you
want to do your own cleaning good for
you you can go to healthcare.gov and
where's there's another chunk oh yes to
access these additional files and so
there are gobs of data down there and so
let me just tell you where this research
is going I guess that's the last slide
that I have before I can happy to take
your questions um which is no that's
actually okay
I'm sort of prepped to do joining of
various databases because I think I've
now got the data in a fairly clean form
but I haven't actually done the joining
there should be there's new data that
should be available shortly and I want
to incorporate that sort of thing I was
hoping to do for today but I was
thwarted by the day not being available
yet I want to do some machine learning
for example to try and figure out what
is a what do we really mean by a PPO
what are those have in common what sort
of clustering characteristics what can
we predict and then I actually don't
know what else I'm going to be able to
find out there what we have is an
unprecedented source one of the things i
guess i'm also interested in is data
binning this data so that if you're
using Mathematica it you now don't have
to do the semantic translation of state
code to state you can actually have it
in there as a state and therefore that
will facilitate you know you now want to
correlate something with population
density okay so you no longer have to go
fishing for what is the population
density of Oklahoma it's it's built in
it's a property of Mathematica built-in
data so I think there's some utility in
trying to make this data set as
Mathematica semantically I don't know
what the right term is semantic import
of this kind of data to facilitate
greater studies so with that I will stop